allez c'est parti pour l'éjaculation
précoce enfin je vous avais compris mais
c'est quoi exactement alors concrètement
une éjaculation précoce tu as trois
caractéristiques déjà elle arrive
rapidement après la pénétration
il y a pas vraiment de durée officielle
mais on parle d'une minute voire deux
maximum et parfois ça peut même arriver
avant la pénétration deuxièmement il y a
une notion d'impossibilité à ce
contrôler elle arrive sans que ce soit
possible de se retenir si vous voulez et
troisièmement c'est vécu négativement
par l'un ou l'autre des partenaires
donc vous voyez c'est des trucs très
objectif et puis il y a quand même une
notion un petit peu subjective qui est
celle de l'insatisfaction et puis il y
en a plusieurs types on parle
d'éjaculation rapide primaire qui a
toujours existé et de secondaire si elle
est apparue dans un second temps et puis
un petit peu comme on avait vu avec la
norgasmi elle peut être permanente ou
intermittente elle peut arriver que
pendant les rapports sexuels mais pas
pendant la masturbation etc etc il y a
plein de cas de figure en fait